hello everyone and welcome to another
most impressive game from round five of
the feed hs dot com grant swiss
currently being played in riga latvia
it's a game between two great attackers
even charity and alexei shirov uh sure
of um
he was uh first he was um playing for
for the soviet union then he played some
four to five years for uh uh latvian and
now he's a spanish player so in case you
you guys were wondering so it's hard to
just say you know this or that player uh
but uh yeah he he plays for spain now if
anyone is interested but um uh that's
not really the point that's just no if
you guys are wondering but the game
itself is brilliant and it always takes
two players to create a brilliant game
and this is one such case so let's dive
straight into it uh shortage with the
white pieces opens with e4 both of them
uh had a great tournament so far both
two wins and two draws and shot rich
even got a draw against caruana with the
black piece so a win in this game for
either of them means basically uh you
know going uh straight straight to the
top uh you know with with alireza uh and
if you guys are wondering what happened
in the alireza maxim bashar lagrave game
uh that game
if you guys don't want to hear it you
know just mute the video for the next
five seconds but the game ended in a
draw uh and i will not be showing it as
it was a really the deadest of draw so
that there's really nothing to show in
that game so it's just a very well uh
played the droish game uh so that's why
i went straight for the at uh this
attacking game with e4 e5 knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 so the
real opus is again on the board with a6
and bishop to a4 we have knight to f6
castles and b5 this is pretty much what
we see in every other video bishop to b3
and bishop to c5 now so developing the
bishop very nicely you know that c3 d4
is coming and the bishop of course will
be retreated uh to b6 we have c3 uh d6
by black and now uh d4 is the most
played move here but charge first throws
in a nice a4 now challenging this b5
pawn rook to b8 and now only now d4 and
now you go back bishop to b6 uh you do
not go bishop to a7 it seems like a
safer square but the problem is this
blunders the game on the spot because
well the the symbol a captures a capture
so now d5 takes away the defender of the
bishop and even if you don't capture
with the pawn if you capture with the
rook again just bishop to a4 and the
black can resign if rogue b6 d5 and you
you again lose a piece so the bishop
must be retreated to b6 and now shot
rich advances the pawn all the way to a5
and we had this so many times
that i i feel it's no longer necessary
to explain why the a5 pawn cannot be
captured but if i'm wrong uh you know uh
mentioned in the comments and the the
next time we reach this position and we
will probably very soon i will mention
it again uh so here a5 bishop back to a7
and h3 now uh we have bishop the b7
should have developed says bishops very
nicely along this diagonal
or along these diagonals so if the
position opens up could be very very
dangerous for white bishop to e3 and now
knight captures an e4 this is all uh
been seen before so nothing to worry
about uh even magnus carlsen had this
position against uh ferugia in
this year's norway chess magnus
continued with knight beat to d2 and he
won that game very nicely but here we
have rook to e1 by shahrich
interestingly shahrich is playing a game
he already played but we're gonna
discuss that so here we have e captures
on d4 c captures on d4 and now d5 i know
the bishop is no longer as powerful and
also the knight is nicely protected here
so knight beat to d2 by sharic and now
we enter the game that
even already had against katrina
but we're gonna discuss that uh a little
bit later so knight to the e7 now the
bishop comes alive also the knight has
additional support here knight captures
an e4 d captures an e4 attacking the
knight here and in the game against the
uh lachna charge went knight to g5 but
here we have knight the e5 and this is
now
as of move 17 a completely new game and
it's interesting obviously um alexa
shirov came prepared and he knew of this
game so it's hard to say who's surprised
who uh did uh shirov um maybe consider
this uh knight advancement instead of
the g5 to e5 and had preparation uh for
for this particular particular line or
was this now uh a surprise for for
shirov who i mean of course um uh had
this uh game in his preparation i it
would amaze me greatly if he didn't uh
but okay uh here we have castles by
shiroff and now queen to g4 now it's
already getting very dangerous you can
see that the bishop is uh
very very strong here the knight is very
well placed the move like bishop to h6
could pose a lot of problems for black
so bishop to d5 here we have to
neutralize white's strong bishop and
even at uh captures on d5 uh very
interesting i will mention is bishop to
h6 right away because it kind of forces
knights to g6 so you don't get
checkmated and now bishop to g5 and this
is where it gets really tricky uh if you
play f6 uh attacking the bishop and
knight then knight to c6 uh attacking
the queen the rook and the bishop and
the knight cannot be captured because
you've you've just played f6 and here we
would see something like queen to d6 uh
and then maybe bishop captures on d5
with check queen captures and now queen
captures on e4 uh and well the game is
pretty much equal you can capture on g5
white can capture on a7 and it's it's
very interesting but it's uh you know
completely unexplored territory so they
would both i'm sure enjoy it uh but
shortage captured on d5 right away we
have queen captures on d5 and now rook
ate the c1 uh this is a a different line
that he chooses but it also allows
shirov to play a very very important
move here and that is c5
and c5 is um
very good for black because you just got
rid of your your backwards c pawn and
also if white captures then the knight
on e5 is no longer defended and here
even has a
a couple of choices really uh the most
obvious one is to just play queen to d7
this is a you know very very drawish
idea but you know it's a really
complicated position so you know we do
not want to be throwing around the word
droish for you know
too easily uh because for example if c
captures on d4 now attacking the bishop
we might even capture on e7 and then if
d captures an e3 f captures uh now okay
the bishop here is kind of hanging but
if the queen ever captures it then you
can capture the knight here but okay
let's say rook b7 attacks the queen now
knight c6 can be played if rook captures
queen we can capture the rook with check
and then pick up black's queen and if
something like rogue d7 then we play
queen back to b4 and it's still a very
very interesting game uh with you know
chances for for both sides uh but in the
game after c5 uh even actually played uh
d captures on c5 he sacrifices the
knight here and now he says that he will
have a great compensation
as he has a past pawn here and also
there are some ideas of queen coming to
d7 with a lot of pressure along the
seventh rank so let's see how this plays
out queen captures an e5 by shiro now
comes bishop to f4 first attacking the
queen also if the queen moves the rook
is on b8 so queen captures on b2 this is
a very important square for the queen if
black is to survive this attack
and now if you go after the rook which
is of course you could always grab back
material you can't capture with the rook
if you capture with the rook then queen
d7 is winning for white now white will
collect too much material but if bishop
captures on b8 then it's perfectly fine
so there's nothing much here for for
white to do you could capture on e4 and
then the game continues knight to g6 but
white doesn't really have compensation
yes that is a beautiful pass pawn but uh
good luck you know crossing that c7
square
so uh instead after queen captures on b2
we have queen to d7 by scharich going
after the knight and the bishop here and
now knight the g6 saying okay you
capture my bishop i'll capture your
bishop on f4 uh and now uh charge plays
bishop to d6 attacks this rook attacks
this rook the bishop is still hanging he
still has his beautiful past pawn and it
seems like uh he uh definitely has
compensation for the sacrifice piece and
he will either recollect the the the
material or he will just have a better
position however there is one thing that
doesn't uh work out for him uh as uh you
know the position always has these uh uh
hidden uh moments uh so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
uh winning and the absolutely crushing
move for shiro while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
beautiful idea as it's really not easy
to understand why and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
pawn to e3 that's the that's the good
stuff that's uh you know how how what
you have played
and this is uh truly uh a remarkable
move especially to be played in in a you
know tournament in riga latvia so now
the thing is if the pawn is captured and
it seems like you could capture the pawn
there's nothing wrong with that of
course not with the rogue because the
rook and c1 hangs but let's say if
capture is on e3 now the problem is rook
f2d8 attacks your queen and let's say
now queen captures on a7 well knights to
h4 and that's it there's no defense
against queen captures on g2 checkmate
there is no move you can play here other
than some silly moves to give up
material uh but you know after that it's
just checkmate so you're not going to be
able to capture that bishop on a7 what
you can do is play something like queen
to c6 or whatever but it doesn't do you
any good for example queen to f6
just saying okay now you can't even
capture the rook because your queen will
will hang and if something like rook to
f1 attacking the black queen queen to e6
and there's nothing for white here uh
white is down material and white does
not have compensation if queen captures
on a6 even bishop captures on c5 the
bishop can't move because the queen
would hang and if something like rook
captures on c5 we simply capture on d6
and if let's say queen a7 attacks the
rook we can even play queen captures on
e3 checking each one rook f8 and white
does not have compensation yes it's a
it's a pass pawn already on a5 but uh
black is a material black also has a
pass pawn uh so nothing to to worry
about here so capturing an e3 does not
work so shotish played rook to f1 but
now e captures on f2 with check again
the pawn cannot be captured of course
this is uh prevented by check and of
course if rook captures queen captures
on c1 so king the h1 was played and now
rook beat the e8 another brilliant move
by shirov saying that if you capture my
bishop now well then i capture your rook
and see one and that's it if rook
captures i just play rook d1 check
and that's it there's nothing you can do
here
or even better
if
after this uh uh rook beat the e8 if you
play something like bishop captures on
f8 uh also doesn't help you it's still
the same thing queen captures on c1 rook
captures and rook to e1 check uh
it looks a bit scary up there uh you
know uh
as the
black king has this bishop on f8
infiltrating and the queen might be able
to join the attack but still just rook
capture sunny one uh getting rid of
check if captures anyone with check king
h2 queen e5 check even that king g1 now
we can play bishop captures on c5 and we
don't care about the back rank for
example if bishop captures queen
captures uh the knight and queen are
guarding the f8 square so it's really
not a problem and you can't even pick up
the pawn with something like this
because the queen covers that square so
the a6 pawn is fine so there's no
compensation here so after rook beat the
e8 rook c to d1 was played but now you
really have no compensation bishop to b8
now you no longer have to worry about
your bishop here
so bishop captures an f8 grabbing at
least some material king captures on f8
and now uh you can't even play c6 if c6
then queen to e5 and you know it's game
over there's no no defending this so you
have to wait before you start pushing
your past pawn g3 is played uh it's a
move that sort of says all right capture
it with the bishop but then at least you
will not be checkmating me but shiro
says not a problem bishop captures on uh
g3 we have c6 and now just queen to c2
and it was in this position i moved 30
that even charity resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh there is no defense against queen to
e4 and that's just game bishop covers h2
pawn covers g1 and uh as you guys always
enjoy it when i finish games even with
the absolute strongest defense let's say
queen to d5 still guarding your pawn and
preventing queen to e4 uh you play
knight h4 and the white has no more
moves there's really nothing you can
play here you can't push the pawn the
queen can't move away from this diagonal
this rook has no squares this rook well
you could move it somewhere but
uh it's real really pointless if you
play something like queen rook to d2
just queen c3 if rook d3 we even play
queen to e1
hoping for this captures and if rook to
d1 as we're really trying to you know
put up the the absolute best defense
here then uh we can simply play king to
g8 get the king to a safer square and
now we don't care what white plays after
some like queen to d3 we're going to
play bishop to c7 and now uh this is
coming this uh rook to e3 followed by
rook captures on h3 checkmate so this is
but this is with the absolute sharpest
defense from white just to show you that
even this is insufficient rook here
attacks the queen after the queen moves
the rook captures on h3 will be
checkmated discovered by the pawn this
is covered by the knight this is covered
by the bishop so everything is covered
there is nothing you could do here of
course eva knows this and after queen
the c2 on move 30 he resigns the game
so really really impressive and the
width of this win as the both of them
were on two wins and two draws shiro is
now on three wins in two draws which
puts him on four points same as uh
alireza ferruja so two of them are
currently in the lead after five rounds
and we'll see what happens uh in in
round six uh let me just check maybe uh
all the
uh or maybe all the games have finished
i doubt it but if they have maybe we do
have uh or no it's it's uh let me just
check uh real quickly yeah okay we still
don't have the pairings as some of the
games are still being played but i will
inform you of course as soon as possible
uh uh who who who he faces next so yeah
that's the game i hope you guys uh
enjoyed it i would like to wish a very
happy birthday to holden and i would
like to thank frank crusoe bryan stuben
uh and jonathan starr for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
magnificent event checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens uh in the chess world uh so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday